welcome to this video play International
Master tortures from Israel Michael
glenn burke okay so going for the
reverse from priyam oh wow I've played
this guy 2 times 2 losses so let's see
this is actually something that I think
is rather okay for black I get the
bishop traded down on c3 normally black
is ok now I'm going to take that
voluntarily make sure that woops takes
with the pawn hmm why then we should be
two in the first place nobody knows ok
I'm playing this in bullet style my
opponents also played those kind of
super committal and probably bad moves
quickly also the whole time so i think i
can try that as well probably it's not
working for me ok
Bishop takes I'll play g5 for Bishop
takes 95 and winning a piece there come
on this is completely completely wacky
but who knows maybe it's dangerous so
he's on this case moving his rook there
so a chick on a form rooks is 6 hmm
I can go Rupe c8 let's try that it looks
like II I know but so okay taking them I
have a pretty pretty nasty pin down on
their farm like 97 here for example a
this this is some pretty serious pin
what is he doing queen a 4 I have fish
about three so this very wacky play
might might succeed at the end okay um I
can take I can also take with the rook I
don't know if it is helpful that's
probably just a self pen
they are taking with the Queen here is a
[ __ ] looks a bit lame to go for the
endgame but i think it's okay quinta
rook takes is some weird self-penned
that doesn't help at all i think i have
to do that especially in regard to Queen
a form rook takes Queen a4 I don't that
don't see a move down and if he takes
rook takes yeah he doesn't I think
that's also better not not taking so
mm-hmm so prime is just f6 so it's
gotcha what to see got five it's gotta
get a bunch of pawns there look f6 maybe
my nights need to be need to be nice
King where am I how am I going to do
that 927
night f7 then g5 and Nagi then g4 i 95
that's an idea maybe he expected that
move maybe it's okay even after the
Queen trade check was not trading Queens
he's not trading Queens because i
blundered d7 great just great how awful
how awful
totally useless it was an interesting
position yeah it really was an
interesting position
check and what is that doing here this
is a terrible game let me check um check
can take everything here now check just
a question can I stop the pawn down
check Suppan
check Queen f5 Chandler my night there's
not able to easily join the giant the
action here that's a problem I need to
need two nite you to join with check if
possible Jack came start with a check
there so anyway to get the night time
playing with check like 92 something
like that would be nice probably not
check
she's got no check now 92 where then is
this check okay
check okay that was helpful white
resigned I already has it son what a
dreadful game yeah Peter should both
take our titles away okay well yeah
maybe this is just um just totally
totally her it's just probably too wacky
but I really felt tempted Bishop TX g5
but he has this rook c7 move and this
refutes the whole thing probably so so
he could have taken and this and wide
wins yeah hmm I thought don't really
know what I thought them probably not
much I have sacrificed four points here
for hmm so this is actually far more
than I deserve to get this one h6 Jim
those pawns 23 it's already awkward yeah
because I probably have to take and this
is awkward those pawns are probably
probably just strong night sir he not
exactly coordinated would have been a
different story if they were somewhere
somewhere active but on those two
squares challenges just blunders the
house it's probably really check its
Plus 8
yet the comp shows plus 16 so it really
this is check here no King everyone and
over and this is this is giving this
from plus 12 or something chat don't
really know yet lots of time check check
just minus one so it's not like a Chang
I'm winning or so check no I should be
winning Queen ahead and Chad g5 was good
okay check yeah then that is winning
from black funny enough and okay this
this is in fact now so easy that that
even though I'm able to win this but it
was one of the really worst games this
this F for business was a bit bit too
much in the spirit of the opening but
just too much okay well thanks for
watching